OF LIBERTY FOR TEMPORARY SAFETY
DESERVE NEITHER NOR LIBERTY NOR
SAFETY.
THAT IS THE "INGRAHAM ANGLE . "
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU ERIC, FIRST
TIME ON "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
SINCE WE STARTED.
WHAT'S YOUR SENSE ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING OUT THERE TODAY?
YOUR DAD HAD AN INCREDIBLE EVENT
AT THE WHITE HOUSE YESTERDAY AND
THE VITRIOL AND VIAL HE RECEIVED
AT THE OTHER END IS TOUGH.
>> I'M PROUD OF HIM.
IT'S THE TOUGHEST SUBJECT.
I JUST HAD A 5-MONTH-OLD CHILD
AND A CAN'T IMAGINE BEING IN THE
SAME ROOM.
THIS COUNTRY IS DOING GREAT ON A
RELATIVE BASIS.
THE ECONOMY IS THROUGH THE ROOF,
UNEMPLOYMENT IS LOWER THAN IT'S
EVER BEEN BEFORE AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN UNEMPLOYMENT IS THE
LOWEST IT'S BEEN AND THE JOBS
ARE COMING BACK AND 401(k)s ARE
UP AND THE VETS ARE BEING HELPED
AND ISIS IS ALMOST GONE AND
DEMOCRATS WILL USE ANYTHING THEY
CAN TO TAKE HIM DOWN BECAUSE
THEY'RE AFRAID OF THEY'LL
SUCCESSES.
I'M NOT SAYING SOMETHING DOESN'T
NEED TO TAKE PLACE OVER THE
TRAGEDY THAT'S HAPPENED BUT MY
HEART BREAKS.
ANYTHING THEY CAN UNDERMINE THE
MAN YOU SAW THE RUSSIAN HOAX,
IT'S SAD AND NOT BENEFICIAL NOR
COUNTRY.
>> Laura: THE OBSESSION OVER THE
CARD HE WROTE IN HIS HAND, IN
THE REAGAN ADMINISTRATION, IF IT
WAS IMPROMPTU WE WOULD GIVE
NOTES.
THEY'RE SAYING YOUR FATHER
DOESN'T CARE.
HE DOESN'T KNOW HOW TO SHOW
EMOTION.
HE'S NOT THE COMFORTER AND CHIEF
OBAMA OR CLINTON OR BUSH WAS.
AND YOU SAY?
>> ANYBODY WHO WATCHED THE TOWN
HALL WHEN THEY'RE SEEING THE
EMOTION FROM THE PARENT AND
TEACHERS AND ONE OF THE --
>> Laura: THEY'RE SAYING YOUR
FATHER DOESN'T HAVE THAT
EMOTION.
THAT'S WHERE THEY ARE.
>> I THINK YOU SAW THE EMOTION
AND IF YOU READ THE POINTS,
THEY'RE BEAUTIFUL POINTS.
I WANT TO HEAR YOU.
I WANT TO KNOW THE FEELINGS EACH
OF YOU HAVE BECAUSE THE FEELINGS
HAVE YOU SITTING IN THAT ROOM
WHILE THE SHOTS WERE TAKING
PLACE -- HE WAS AMAZING
YESTERDAY.
HE WAS AMAZING YESTERDAY AND A
WAS PROUD OF HIM AND FRANKLY I
THINK IT'S THE FIRST STEP IN
HEALING A NATION THAT'S DEEPLY
TROUBLED BY WHAT'S HAPPENED.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK WE SHOULD
RAISE THE AGE OF WHEN SOMEONE
CAN BUY SEMIAUTOMATIC RIFLES.
>> I'M A BIG SECOND AMENDMENT
AMERICAN BUT I ALSO THINK
SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE.
IT'S SAD TO SEE WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
I'M A BIG FAN OF BACKGROUND
CHECKS AND OTHER THINGS.
I ALSO THINK THERE'S A
SYSTEMATIC PROBLEM IN SOCIETY
THAT HAS TO BE ADDRESSED.
HOW DO YOU SOLVE -- AND I'VE
STRUGGLED WITH THIS THE LAST
COUPLE DAYS.
HOW DO YOU SOLVE THE PROBLEM OF
EVIL IN SOCIETY.
THAT PERSON WAS NOT RIGHT.
>> THE SECURITY CAMERAS WERE NOT
OPERATING IN REAL TIME.
THEY WERE ON A SEVERAL MINUTE
DELAY.
A 10-MINUTE DELAY OR LONGER AND
THE SECURITY GUARD THAT WAS
ARMED --
>> THOSE ARE THE LAY-UPS BUT HOW
DO YOU SOLVE EVIL IN SOCIETY.
I THINK WE NEED TO DO A BETTER
JOB AS PARENTS AND IN SOCIETY
AND ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
I THINK WE NEED TO DO A BETTER
JOB MENTORING OUR YOUTH.
THERE'S SO MANY ASPECTS.
I THINK THERE'S COMMON SENSE
THINGS THAT CAN BE DONE AND I
ALSO THINK THERE'S SOCIETAL
PROBLEMS.
>> Laura: WE DIDN'T HAVE THIS
PROBLEM WHEN I GREW UP.
WE HAD MORE GUNS IN CONNECTICUT
WHEN I GREW UP AND FIRE DRILLS.
SOMETHING'S CHANGED BETWEEN THE
LATE '70s AND EARLY '80s AND
TODAY.
I DON'T KNOW IF LEGISLATION CAN
CHANGE THAT.
YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN GETTING A LOT
OF HEAT FOR YOUR BROTHER'S
TRAVEL TO INDIA AND BUSINESS
HE'S DOING THERE.
HE GAVE A SPEECH ON
INDO-AMERICAN RELATIONS AND
YOU'RE GETTING HAMMERED.
BOB MENENDEZ SAID I'M CONCERNED,
MR. TRUMP, YOUR BROTHER'S
SPEECH, WILL BE MISTAKEN HE'LL
BE COMMUNICATING OFFICIAL
AMERICAN POLICY AND THE PRESENCE
IN INDIA WILL HAVE NO ROLE IN
SUPPORTING MR. TRUMP DURING HIS
TIME IN INDIA NEW YORK MAGAZINE
AND THE REST OF THE NASTY
COMMENTS ABOUT THIS.
ANY CONFLICT THERE GIVEN THE
BUSINESS INTERESTS THERE ON
POLICY --
>> WHAT DON'T WE GET HAMMERED
FOR?
MY BROTHER WAS OVER THERE.
WE HAVE A BUNCH OF BUILDING IN
INDIA.
HE'S TALKING HOW THE INDIAN
PEOPLE ARE WONDERFUL PEOPLE AND
ENJOYED THE EXPERIENCE AND THEN
HAVE YOU THIS.
THESE THE FIRST PEOPLE THAT SAY
THE FIRST AMENDMENT SHOULD BE
PROTECTED UNTIL YOU SAY
SOMETHING THEY DISAGREE WITH AND
THEN THEY WANT TO RIP YOU TO
SHREDS.
WE'VE BEEN THERE MANY YEARS AND
THERE'S LITTLE WE CAN DO WE
DON'T GET ATTACKED FROM AND YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT IT IN YOUR
OPEN.
I THINK YOU DID SO BEAUTIFULLY.
THERE'S NOTHING WE DON'T GET
ATTACKED FOR BECAUSE QUIETLY THE
DEMOCRATS DON'T HAVE THEIR OWN
PLATFORM AND NO GOOD LEADERSHIP
OR IDEAS OR GOOD BENCH OF
CANDIDATE.
THEY'RE PETRIFIED BY PEOPLE
HAVING MONEY IN THEIR POCKETS
THEY ATTACK OUR KIDS, OUR WIVES,
JARED AND IVANKA.
THEY DO EVERYTHING TO UNDERMINE
OUR FAMILY BECAUSE IT'S THE ONLY
MOVE THEY HAVE.
>> Laura: YOU HAVE SOMEBODY
INTERNALLY --
>> AND WE TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
WE TAKE THAT SO SERIOUSLY.
>> Laura: YOU'RE UNDER THE MICRO
SCOPE SO YOU HAVE TO TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY.
MANAFORT AND THERE'S NEW CHARGES
THE CONCERN IS TRYING TO SQUEEZE
MANAFORT TO EXPOSE TRUMP IN THE
NEVER-ENDING INVESTIGATION.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IT'S
INTERESTING?
>> WITH RUSSIA THEY DUG AND DUG
AND FINDLY -- FINALLY FOUND
THEMSELVES AND YOU HEAR HOW
CRAZY ABOUT THE DOSSIER PAID FOR
BY THE SAME PEOPLE AND THEY DUG
SO DEEP THEY FOUND THEMSELVES.
EVERYTHING CAME FULL CIRCLE.
I WAS IN THE CAMPAIGN AND HE HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH RUSSIA AND HE
WORKED HARD AND SOLD THE BETTER
MESSAGE AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WANTED A BUSINESS MAN NOT A
CAREER POLITICIAN.
IT HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
RUSSIANS.
THERE WERE NO RUSSIANS.
IT'S A NONSENSE.
THE WHOLE THING HAS BEEN A HOAX
AND THEY CAUGHT THEMSELVES IN
THE PROCESS.
I HOPE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT -- I
HOPE THEY DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
>> Laura: IS JEFF SESSIONS DOING
ENOUGH TO INVESTIGATE THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION'S INVOLVEMENT
WITH PUSHING THAT PHONY DOSSIER
KNOWING WHO FUNDED IT AND
KNOWING WHAT WAS BEHIND IT AND
WHO WAS BEHIND IT?
>> I DON'T KNOW BUT I HOPE HE IS
BECAUSE IT'S SAD AND DISGUSTING
AND SO MANY FACT HAVE COME TO
LIGHT AND THEY'RE BAD FACTS.
THEY'RE BAD FACTS FOR THE OTHER
SIDE.
IT'S DEEPLY TROUBLING.
WE BETTER BE DOING SOMETHING
ABOUT IT OTHERWISE THERE'S A LOT
OF UNJUSTICE IN THE COUNTRY.
>> Laura: WE HAVE A LOT OF
UNMASKING OF AMERICAN CITIZENS
DONE BY INDIVIDUALS AND WE DON'T
KNOW ON WHAT GROUNDS.
>> I'D LOVE TO SEE THE LIST OF
WHO THE INDIVIDUALS WERE.
>> Laura: YOU MIGHT HAVE BEEN,
WHO KNOWS.
>> I WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED.
>> Laura: ARE YOU HAPPY YOU
STAYED IN THE BUSINESS WORLD
AND -- PEOPLE ASK ME ALL THE
TIME AND I KNOW I'M DOING THE
RIGHT THING NOW BUT YOU SEE WHAT
YOUR FATHER GOES THROUGH AND HE
COULD BE DOING ANYTHING AND HE'S
DOING THIS.
>> HE MADE A TREMENDOUS
SACRIFICE IN HIS OWN LIFE AND
HALF OF ME WOULD LIKE TO BE BY
HIS SIDE FIGHTING WITH HIM AND
THAT'S THE FAMILY WE ARE AND
HE'S AN AMAZING MAN AND
INCREDIBLE PRESIDENT BUT AT THE
SAME TIME I LOVE BUILDING
BUILDINGS AND I WOULD LOVE TO BE
THERE PROTECTING HIM EVERY DAY
BUT HE'S DOING A GOOD JOB AND
MAKING ME VERY PROUD.
>> Laura: WHAT I DON'T LIKE IS
WHEN PEOPLE SAY HE DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT THE PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW WHO WHOM.
HE DOESN'T CARE ABOUT THE
BLANKING PEOPLE.
>> HE DID THIS FOR ONE REASON,
FOR THE PEOPLE.
THEY WERE BEING FORGOTTEN.
THEY WERE BEING LEFT BEHIND.
GOVERNMENT WAS WALKING ALL OVER
THEM AND EVERY DAY WHEN WALKED
DOWN THE STREET I HEAR FROM
THOSE PEOPLE, TELL YOUR FATHER
WE SAY THANK YOU.
HE'S DOING AN AMAZE JOB FOR THIS
COUNTRY AND THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE PUNCHES YOU DO AS A FAMILY